China now, it has denounced the decision to impose restrictions...
…on Chinese travelers because of the rising COVID infections...
…and warned it might take reciprocal action.
International health officials have criticized Beijing...
…for failing to release data on the spread of the virus...
…and possible new variants.
The U.S. and about a dozen other countries will require those arriving from China...
...to produce negative test certificates.
Many Chinese have been rushing to book their first overseas trips in years,...
…after Beijing lifted its own travel restrictions.
Well, Chinese Foreign Ministry spokesperson condemned the requirements on travelers.
We are willing to strengthen communication with the international community...
…and work hard together to overcome the epidemic.
At the same time, we also believe that some countries have imposed entry restrictions...
…targeting only Chinese travelers.
This lacks scientific basis and some practices are unacceptable.
We firmly oppose any attempts to manipulate epidemic prevention measures...
...in order to achieve political goals.
We will take countermeasures based on the principle of reciprocity.